Bánh bán nhân dân tính bắt nền để sốt chính sách hỗ trợ Chí Phi Lưu Chú và Zi Chuyển Chocan Bộ.
Công chức, viên chức người là động phải thay đổi nơi làm việc khi sắp đơn vị hành chính cấp tình.
Cấp xa.
Dự kiến, khoảng cách Zi Chuyển Tự 2.000 km để giới 3.000 km, hỗ trợ bà trợ động một người trên thắng,
khoảng cách Zi Chuyển Tự 3.000 km để giới 4.000 km, hỗ trợ bà trợ bà trợ bà trợ bà trợ bà trợ bà trợ nghìn động một người trên thắng.
Quảng cách Zi Chuyển Tự 4.000 km để giới 5.000 km, hỗ trợ bún triệu 5.000 đồng một người trên thắng,
khoảng cách Zi Chuyển Tự 5.000 km, hỗ trợ 5.000 đồng một người trên thắng.
Đối với địa bàng cắt sát thục vùng đồng bào dinh tục thiệu số và mình lối trước thời điểm sắp,
thì khoảng cách Zi Chuyển Tự 3.000 km sò với quy định trên.
Thử dân hỗ trợ tương ngày 1 táng bẩy nắm hành hủ trăm hai 1 năm đến ngày 3.000 tằng sấu năm hành hủ trăm hai 1 bẩy.
Tổng kinh phí sự kiến khoảng 18.000 tỉ đồng trên năm, thời gian hỗ trợ trong 2 năm là 1 trăm bún mới bẩy tỉ đồng.